[Musique]
bonjour elle s'appelle claudine elle a
26 ans elle mesure 1 mètre soixante dix
en 1976 elle peser 82 kg aujourd'hui
elle en pèse 40 2 vous nous avez l'écrit
claudine parce que vous êtes en
dépression nerveuse vous nous avez aussi
écrit que vous étiez en dépression
depuis sept ans commence at-il commencé
ça commençait à la suite d'un régime
amaigrissant
ordonné par un médecin en milieu médical
d'ailleurs
je commençais à travailler cette année
là je me suis marié cette année-là j'ai
déménagé
et
tout s'est enchaîné j'ai j'ai eu de
graves problèmes au travail
et puis j'ai commencé à couler au début
je me rendais pas bien compte
bon jeu mais je tiens je me sens moins
gai
et puis j'ai sombré aussi dans
l'anorexie mentale
vous avez commencé à couler ça se
manifester comme en
jeu briller - et surtout je n'avais plus
envie de la fin je n'avais plus le même
besoin de faire rire les autres
j'ai commencé à nous à m'isoler des gens
je
vous pensez qu'il ne voulait plus vous
pensiez à l'époque oui je cours c'est
surtout ça c'est c
j'ai toujours eu peur d'eux de leur
regarde vous dites toujours pourquoi
toujours
pas ce que tu as vu que je suis tout
tout petit bond majeur
je cherche à plaire aux gens enfin comme
tout le monde oui
mais maintenant j'ai surtout peur de ce
qu'ils peuvent penser de ce qu'ils
peuvent savoir
de ce qui pourrait me condamner mais
vous condamnez pourquoi
mais pour ce que ça fait qu'est ce que
vous faites
c'est quand même pas très normal de
manger ou de refuser de manger vous de
manger et dormir
vous êtes mariés depuis sept ans oui
votre mari comment est-il comment
réagit-il devant cette maladie
je pense qu'il attend et il ne me fait
pas c'est nous d'ailleurs n'ont pas
jamais
moi non plus thème rien parler avec lui
oui vous avez essayé
oui mais je sens que lui non plus n'aime
pas tellement en parler
je pense que ça le choc
peut-être
avec qui en parlez vous alors
j'ai un médecin enfin
et
j'ai une soeur aussi
qui est au courant
parce que je crois qu'elle a commencé
enfin elle a eu certains problèmes elle
aussi
mais c'était purement digestif d'un
risque moi c'est vraiment dans la tête
en plus vos parents sont éloignés de
vous depuis que vous êtes marié de pour
nous inviter plus à côté d'eux est ce
que vous croyez que ça ça a été une
cassure est quelque chose qui vous a
manqué beaucoup oui c'était
une question
parce que je je me rends bien compte
par moments quand je suis prêt deux
camps jeu
ça m'embête
de toujours revenir au même sujet mais
quand je mange chez chez eux quelquefois
ça se passe beaucoup mieux
vous forcer à vomir
je me force au début oui puis maintenant
c'est c'est presque spontanée
vous ne pouvez pas garder de la
nourriture dans votre estomac ah non
pourquoi nous
c'est
j'ai l'impression que c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas destinée peu de
choses
que je ne peux pas garder que
quelque chose qui est sa famille qui ne
m'appartient pas juste
que je n'ai pas le le le droit de garder
c'est
qu'est ce que vous faites de vos
journées claudine qu'est-ce que vous
comment les passez vous
on ne mangeait pas
le matin aux
sapins sont géré assez vite
et l'après midi jeux j'ai l'impression
de vivre terrée chez moi dans
mon
jeu je me renferme ça
n'allait pas voir de spectacle qui
pourrait vous distraire vous ne lisez
pas
si je lis un peu mais
ça m'intéresse moins qu'avant j'ai j'ai
l'impression d'être beaucoup moins
ouvert sur le monde
vous avez l'impression que vos facultés
intellectuelles on a huy ont baissé oui
on y joue
jeu je rends compte que
je suis moins intéressé je juge oublie
certaines choses ça je suis beaucoup
plus discrète mais
istres est
dans le source de l'oubli
et j'attrapais des migraines des fois
rien rien faire vous avez envie de
sortir de tout ça
maintenant oui par moments même même pas
parce que cette façon de ne pas manger
parce qu'au début vraiment
c'était une façon de de me laisser
mourir
enfin on attend même maintenant en cause
je me dis mais
pourquoi est ce qu'on n'en meurt pas il
en a d'ailleurs qui en meurent mais ce
que vous n'aimez pas suffisamment ce qui
vous entoure pourrait avoir envie de
vivre pour eux quand vous vous êtes
mariés il ya sept ans vous n'étiez pas
dans cet état là où ça commençait
ce à commencer face
à caen ce oui c'était vraiment les
prémices plus tôt mais quand je pense
justement à ceux qui m'entourent mais
c'est c'est encore pire pour moi parce
que je me dis que je leur fais du mal
en me faisant à moi mais alors comme je
leur fait du mal je me sens coupable de
vouloir faire ça et ça me ronge
davantage encore mais vous savez qui
vous aime
oui enfin je l'espère est ce que vous
avez envie de le redevenir comme vous
l'étiez en 1976 avant de maigrir
avant un an au nom
même du village vous avez vous aussi
vécu une dépression nerveuse vous en
êtes maintenant sorti excuses dans les
symptômes décrits par claudine vous vous
reconnaissez
disons que si je me remémore un peu la
dépression de laquelle je sors
actuellement j'en ai refait j'en ai fait
une aussi ya vingt ans et je me rends
compte que quand je fait l'analogie d2
je me rends compte que c'est toujours
une dépression en fonction de grand
changement dans ma vie donc j'en ai fait
une à l'âge de 18 ans je vais avoir
bientôt 38 ans et
chaque fois quand il ya une rupture très
importante dans ma vie bon notre mais
rupture c'était
une crèche où je m'occupais des enfants
et mes parents comme en belgique la
majorité est à 21 ans mes parents n'ont
pas voulu que je continue à travailler
dans cette crèche donc on en a retiré et
ici l'année dernière
j'ai arrêté librement de travailler
professionnellement et puis disons que
il est évident que les premières les
premiers mois j'étais très heureuse est
à la maison parce que si vous voulez
quand on travaille avec des enfants on
se dit bon ben je précise fressin n'y a
pas de problème j'avais énormément de
projets
et en définitive au bout de 4 5 points
d'inactivité professionnelle mais quand
même d'activités familiales et de
maisons et d'amis et tout ce que vous
voulez je pense qu'il s'est passé quoi
j'ai sombré je ne n'ai pas pu comprendre
à ce moment là comment ça a commencé
vous rappeler mais disons que si je me
rappelle c'est très très spécial parce
que ans mais je me suis senti très mal
je parle donc du mois de mai de l'année
dernière
et je me souviens que pendant deux mois
mon premier médecin traitant m'a traitée
pour une hépatite virale
bon alors c'est à dire que j'avais des
symptômes physiologiques qu'ils
pouvaient déclencher pas mal de
problèmes et de fil en aiguille dans le
courant du 3ème mois on a écarté
complètement
l'hépatite virale et puis on m'a pas
spécifié ce que j'avais on m'a prescrit
des médicaments
je dirais que personnellement j'avais le
sentiment de gêne et ce médecin que
j'étais un cap 6 ou quelque chose de ce
genre je dis c'est pas possible je me
suis dit bon comment m'en sortir
toujours est il qu'à ce moment là il m'a
prescrit des médicaments
là j'ai traversé une période comme il
traversait le désert incroyable parce
que ces médicaments ne me convenait pas
du tout et je dormais jour et nuit ce
devenait vraiment épouvantable et puis
un jour je me suis sentie train
tellement malade
il ya eu des amis qui étaient à la
maison elle a téléphoné à mon médecin
traitant
il n'a pas voulu se déplacer
conclusion elle a dit bah écoutes je
peux pas te laisser comme ça je vais
appeler mon médecin traitant qui lui
quelques heures en prêt est venu me
rendre visite je lui ai montré les
médicaments
que j'avais que je prenais à ce moment
là je lui ai donné tous les tests de
prises de sang et incite ces deux choses
qui avait été faite au préalable me
d'écouté
je vous propose d'arrêter tous ces
médicaments là je me ferais une certaine
série de tests
mais je pense que ces gens de
médicaments ne vous convient pas du tout
il vous aviez vous étiez en dépression
nerveuse non il n'ya pas utiliser le mot
non plus
alors je suis allé le voir à plusieurs
reprises à son cabinet de consultation
bien sûr je sentais bien que ça n'allait
pas parce que j'avais des envies
constante de pleurer et la dernière fois
que je me suis retrouvé dans son cabinet
de consultation qui date du début de
janvier ils ont collaboré c'était les
grandes où j'ai pleuré je ne savais plus
où j'en étais alors j'ai discuté avec
lui je donc ce n'est pas un médecin
spécialisé c'est un généraliste et alors
je lui racontais un peu tout ce qui se
passe est que je me sentais inutile
que j'allais avait l'impression comme du
fait que j'avais un travail arrêtée de
travailler professionnellement que je
n'était plus valable en tant que
personne parce que étant donné que du
fait que j'avais travaillé j'avais rendu
mon mari et mes enfants responsable donc
nous avions une répartition des tâches
qui faisait que nous étions enfin tout
tout tout s'était très autonome en
faisant un quoi ce qui a fait que hbo je
me suis dit du jour au lendemain je peux
pas à nouveau infantiliser les enfants
que j'ai parce que bon de 4 à 10 2 de 10
à 18 ans je pense que c'est vraiment la
joue il faut les rendre autonomes cela
vous avez trois enfants de 14 et 18 14
et 18 tu es bien nicole comment a réagi
votre entourage
disons que
comme le mot dépression n'a jamais été
utilisée j'étais fort entouré dans ce
sens que tout le monde
le savait malade puisque il y a eu des
erreurs de diagnostic qui ont fait que
en définitive il n'y avait pas
d'hépatite puis ensuite quand j'ai
découvert que je prenais quand même des
médicaments moi personnellement je
savais bien j'ai fait une dépression
vous vous vous le saviez jeu de ce oui
oui mais comment les aviez vous je m'en
suis rendu compte parce que je n'avais
plus de goût à rien et je me faisais un
jeu personnel quoi parce que tu y sont
que un jeu personnel je m'explique dans
ce sens que j'ai toujours eue si vous
voulez une façade de femmes fortes
et j'avais un peu l'impression que je
retombais de mon piédestal et que
j'avais pas envie de montrer ce visage
la coi qu'est ce que vous attendiez des
autres de vos proches bien disons que je
pense que je n'en attendais pas grand
chose je crois que c'est très mal
expliqué c'est ce passage à vide parce
que hbo j'étais entouré par rapport à ma
famille mon mari mes enfants et les amis
mais comme le mot en tant que telle
dépression n'avait jamais été prononcé
moi je le savais mais je vous dirais
sincèrement que je les prononcer est mis
sur la feuille quand je vous ai écrit
quoi c'est à dire tout à fait récemment
récemment oui madame alrivie vous vous
avez craqué d'un seul coup
non j'avais un terrain propice tout
petit j'ai fait
une crise anorexie de les symptômes la
puberté et j'avais quand même un terrain
propice étant quelqu'un de très très
émotive et d'anxieux zh mais tout a
craqué parce que
mon ex mari pendant nous avons vécu 14
ans ensemble
avait perdu son emploi en tant que
journaliste reporter et
il sombre dans l'alcoolisme et j'ai tenu
14 ans et
j'ai tenu tenu un peu comme madame qui
viennent par les jeux j'avais aussi une
façade de femmes fortes et puis je me
suis forgé cette façade est en
définitive
je pense que je portais cet homme à bout
de bras je sais moi qui menait les
affaires du ménage qui
faisait l'échec il n'avait plus de
travail
et
j'ai commencé à m'adresser à mon médecin
traitant il montre comment ça a commencé
et bien moi j'avais des maux de tête d'
absolument terrible
donc j'ai continué à travailler pour moi
c'était ma seule planche de salut de
toute manière il y avait qu un seul
salaire dans le ménage c'était important
pour moi de rester plutôt que de voir
quelqu'un inactifs et sombrer dans la
boisson à la maison
par des mots terribles des névralgies
qui durait une heure ou deux au travail
j'étais devenu très irritable très
versatile envers les gens je n'avais
plus tellement confiance mis en moi n'y
en eu
ou par divers autres symptômes
que je n'arrive pas à exprimer
maintenant mais
on vous donnera la parole mme anna marie
vit bien sûr madame
denise
vous vous avez eu votre première crise
de descente et de dépression première
avec crise oui à l'âge de 17 ans j'ai
fait une tentative de suicide mais ça
avait commencé quelques mois auparavant
comme comme madame par des maux de tête
pas très violent mais plutôt continue
qui est qui qui troublait s'était pas
plage était lycéenne et ça perturbait
complètement
mais à ce moment là à ce moment là est
ce que vos parents vous emmener
consulter c'est comme envoyer oui pour
les maux de tête pour savoir qu'est ce
que c'est à il fallait absolument que ce
soit une maladie physique
[Musique]
est alors à chaque fois les résultats
étaient négatifs ou 10x avait rien ça se
manifester comme en dehors des maux de
tête
alors là en dehors des maux de tête
depuis très longtemps ça allait très mal
mais c'est à l'intérieur de moi je ne
manifestaient pas mes parents l'ignorait
je meurs je me souviens qu'à l'âge de
huit ans mais je n'en parlais qu'à des
camarades de classe j'avais envie de
mourir déjà wii est bon je le disais des
camarades de classe et ne prenait pas au
sérieux
et puis et puis bombe
claudine dit quelque chose je vous
redonne la parole de type 2 dit claudine
oui moi aussi j'ai les dignes fois ma
mère je voudrais me jeu je voudrais
mourir et puis elle a ri jeudi que l'
ange avait
8 10 en mars en rire c'était pire que
bien il y a quelqu'un que je ne vous ai
pas encore présenté sur ce plateau il
s'agit du docteur louis bertagna il est
l'un des grands spécialistes sinon le
spécialiste de la dépression en france
et il est l'un des introducteurs dans
notre pays de tout ce qui est
chimiothérapie et particulièrement le
traitement par le lithium louis
bertignac et psychiatres monsieur votre
présence sur ce plateau et pourrait
laisser entendre que
quand on est dépressive quand on est en
dépression nerveuse on doit aller voir
un psychiatre cela veut-il dire qu'on
est fous
sur vont pas et c'est une des choses sur
lesquelles il faut insister
le mot de dépression est très souvent
très mal vécu voyez-vous tout à l'heure
madame deghilage nous disait que n'avait
pas vue de spécialistes et qu'elle avait
employé ce mot tout récemment seulement
dans les familles dire de quelqu'un de
la famille qu'il est déprimée c'est un
peu un des zones l enfance quand on
trouve des ascaris quand on trouve des
obscurs rentre on trouve la fameuse
appendicite chronique celle au maire qui
a restitué à la famille
ce sont tous ces fameux bouc émissaire
salvateur parce que ils viennent
introduire l'élément somatiques qui est
lui parfaitement avouables or la
dépression non seulement est
parfaitement avoir et je dirais même que
pour moi dire de quelqu'un qu'il a été
déprimé c'est presque lui rendent un
hommage non pas que je souhaite à
quiconque d'être déprimé car il n'y a
pas d'épreuve plus épouvantable que la
dépression mais la dépression existe je
la rencontre tous les jours et pour vous
donner une idée de son important je veux
donner quelques chiffres il y a en
permanence dans un pays comme le nôtre
3%
de personnes qui sont en dépression
grave 3% sas exception et million et
demi de personnes en permanence qui sont
en dépression grave c'est-à-dire qu'ils
connaissent l'épreuve la plus
épouvantable qu'ils soient si on définit
la gravité d'une maladie par la douleur
la douleur morale la dépression est pire
que toutes les douleurs physiques je
n'ai jamais vu un malade est primé qui
est éprouvée par ailleurs ce plan
physique ne pas dire mille fois la
maladie physique plutôt que ma
dépression je me permets de vous arrêter
monsieur c'est le cas de madame alviri
qui est arrivé qui est à côté de vous
elle a fait une dépression tout de suite
après on lui a on a pratiqué sur elle
une hystérectomie et finalement elle
nous a écrit non pas pour nous parler de
cette hystérique tommy monsieur mais
pour nous parler de sa dépression bien
sûr mais je peux voter une histoire très
brièvement une de mes mains à qui avez
connu l'enfer de la dépression pendant
dix ans c'est des pressions cycliques
répétitives et puis on l'a mis sous
lithium et sa vie a été transformée elle
avait par ailleurs de nos vies très
éprouvés et un jour elle me téléphone
elle un cancer du sein est un cancer du
sein pas de la meilleure espèce on est
obligé de loperhet l'objet de l'ue fait
de la chimiothérapie en effet les rayons
tout ça n'est pas tellement il faut bien
le dire remonte
mais elle tient le coup admirablement et
comme je la félicite me dit m'enfin
docteur es ce que vous avez oublié et ce
que j'ai oublié le béaba de votre métier
jeudi qu'elle b à ba enfin vous savez
bien que quand on a connu la dépression
un cancer du sein même un com et chant
cancer du sein c'est des roses et vous
ceci exprime bien donc la douleur de la
dépression est la pire de toutes
sihanouk critères de danger de l'habiter
d'une maladie c'est l'invalidité
la vanité professionnelle et familiale
la dépression est terriblement
destructrice l empêche de travailler et
elle empoisonne la vie de famille et si
un autre critère de gravité des maladies
c'est le risque demeure la dépression
est la seule maladie j'en connais pas
d'autre qui entraîne le suicide il n'y a
pas d'autres maladies ou le suicide soit
un symptôme de la maladie non pas du
tout que ce serait très fréquent grâce à
dieu mais il est quand même curieux que
la seule m'a dit si bien la seule qui
entraîne le suicide comme conséquence
logique de ce qu'elle est soit la seule
de toutes les maladies la seule à
laquelle ils souhaitent habituel est
souvent de bon ton de ne pas croire
madame karuna que des comment comment
alors à 17 ans au moment où en plus
l'adolescence où c'est encore plus
difficile comment avez vous échapper à
ce drame dont parle le docteur eggman
justement ça me fait quelque chose parce
que moi je suis échappé parce que ça a
raté mais je vous assure que la première
fois on tente de se suicider enfin pour
moi j'avais vraiment envie de mourir bon
j'ai horreur de la violence j'ai pas je
suis pas passée sous un train j'ai avalé
des médicaments que je pensais ne pas me
réveiller je me suis réveillé manque de
pot enfin non temps maintenant mais
harry pas que c'est ce que je me suis
dit c'est malheureusement j'ai un cousin
qui a fait une dépression
on s'en est pas aperçu on aurait pu s'en
apercevoir il a fait une tentative de
suicide il a réussi du premier coup on
n'a rien pu faire et c'est terrible et
je crois que des pressions c'est une
maladie très dangereuse oui il ya tout
certains leur éclosion est atteint bien
sûr il ya plusieurs types de dépression
la plus connue la plus classique ce
qu'on appelle à des pressions
mélancolique la dépression mélancolique
et une dépression la dépression majeure
c'est la plus grave de tout et
elle alterne parfois avec son symétrique
qui est exactement inverse mais qui
correspond même des règlements des
fonctions cérébrales qui est ce qu'on
est à ce qu'on appelle des états
d'hypomanie ou de manille c'est à dire
c'est un état alain vers sa dépression
on est abattu on est pessimiste où on se
sent tout à fait finie b on est anxieux
où on a envie de rien où tout est un
problème ou se lever s'habiller net une
difficulté majeure pour une femme faire
le menu le repas de midi c'est
abominable ne parlons pas de faire la
valise alors là c'est un choix devant
lequel on est complètement bloqué cette
dépression là qui comporte souvent une
très mauvaise conscience à sentiment
d'incapacité à compter marie culpabilité
un sentiment d'inefficacité le sentiment
aussi qu'on gêne les autres qu'on les
encombrent qu' on est coupable et
connaît même parfois comédien toutes ses
grandes caractéristiques de dépression
sont très particulière à la dépression
mélancolique qui est la plus grave de
toutes est une chose utile tout de suite
parce que c'est très important comme
repère c'est que ce sont les symptômes
qui 8 fois sur 10 chez les primés sont
au maximum le matin les déprimés sont
généralement au plus mal le matin et
dans l'après midi et le soir ils sont
mieux
c'est très souvent cela et c'est
tellement ça que je dis que j'ai deux
fois plus de malades que j'ai l'air d'en
avoir parce que je suis le matin tu sois
mais pas le même car on nous appelle le
matin au secours on nous dit j'en peux
plus ne m'obligez plus à travailler et
quand on revoit ses malades le soin pour
envisager une hospitalisation ils sont
remontés sur la bête et ils ne sont plus
d'accord du tout mais si on les écoute
le matin on se retrouve devant problème
ça c'est la dépression mélancolique avec
son symétrique et qui est la phase
d'excitation qu'il faut quand même est
évoqué ici parce que c'est important
madame oui je suis sur les périodes on
est véritablement le mot n'est pas
français en sueur force alors on se sent
examinations on comprend tout libanais
ont fait on a envie de tout on achète
tout quand on est déprimé on peut pas
faire un achat d'abord on a envie de
rien et ensuite il faut choisir et enfin
on a souvent dit d'héroïne c'est à dire
la pop de penser dessous au contraire
quand on est bien alors là tout y passe
et puis on ne fait que des affaires on
revient avec des achats faits fou mais
chacun est une affaire et on veut se
faire applaudir on veut se faire
acclamer et j'ai eu souvent comme ça des
malades dans cet état là qui comprenait
pas que leurs femmes les remercie pas de
l'art portait un manteau très cher alors
qu'ils n'ont pas de quoi payer le
téléphone est dissipée
enfin je veux dire il ya les deux en
fait dans mon cas spécifique je passe
par des femmes en fait on aime on est
jetés cyclothymique c'est à dire
jusqu'en n'ai pas de cycle
il s'agit de dépression oui on ne fait
pas dans la nuance c'est un moment
important alors il ya deux jours ensuite
mon sens qui est dit à leurs claudine
veux pas parler l'anorexie mentale de
ses poèmes très particulier à
l'intérieur des dépressions et même un
problème tellement particulier qu'une
des choses qui tient un testing la
russie mental très souvent c'est
l'activité des anorexiques n'est pas
elles sont à la fois misérable avoir est
étonnante
par l'activité qu'elle déploie mais ya
une chose qui nous a fait certainement
les uns et les autres qui nous a fait
réfléchir c'est qu'elle s'est mariée
elle nous a parlé de son mari je veux
dire que 1 des problèmes de dépression
c'est l'entourage et que si la
dépression est effectivement un malheur
épouvantable pour le déprimé est une
épreuve également très grande victoire
car les gens n'ont pas du tout
l'habitude de réfléchir en termes de
dépression et pas autant au devant d'une
appendicite devant une tuberculose
devant un diabète légende érection saine
et normale devant la dépression c'est
l'incompréhension prenez un jeune garçon
qui se marie avec une femme qu'il a
connue vivante et
dynamique bien beaux jours cette femme
la plus envie de rien faire saby tous
les jours de la même façon pleurs
n'a pas envie de sortir quand on le lui
propose ce garçon est très malheureux
parce qu'il lui semble que il devrait
pouvoir en étant avec sa femme comme à
marie doit l'être qui devrait pouvoir
dépasser cette difficulté qui devrait
lui permettre à sa femme de la surmonter
et il vit sa dépression à des pressions
de sa femme comme un échec de sa propre
présence auprès d'elle il est
extrêmement dur extrêmement dure et
c'est une des choses vérifie que le
déprimé et très mal perçue dans sa
famille parce qu'on finit par lui en
vouloir de ne pas mieux réagir de ne pas
mieux répondre à tous les efforts qu'on
fait pour lui et on finit par avoir des
formules qui sont abominables du genre
on dirait que tu te complais danton et à
vraiment j'avais un des villages si ça
peut être généralisé parce que moi en
tout cas j'ai jamais eu l'impression
d'avoir dérangé tout à voir mes enfants
et mon mari parce que vous êtes vous
avez la chance d'avoir un mari et des
enfants qui étaient probablement
exceptionnellement près de vous et
compréhensive moi je peux dire que je
suis parfois choper en particulier par
l'intolérance des jeunes enfants quand
une femme de 45 50 ans fait une
dépression s'est souvent sa fille de 25
ans qui est la plus impitoyable secoue
toi prends sur toi assume toi c'est ton
problème c'est pas le mien et c'est très
curieux cette espèce de radicalisme des
jeunes qui sont souvent les pires
bourreaux n'est ce pas de deux personnes
qui n'ont déjà que trop tendance à se
sentir coupable bien sûr et je vous
assure qu'il m'est arrivé plus d'une
fois devoir
une personne se suicider non seulement
parce qu'elle ne supportait pas de vivre
et parce qu'elle pensait qu'elle allait
débarrasser son entourage d'une présence
encore
sais pas c'est pas le 4 c'est pas le cas
pour ça que je posais la question de
savoir si ça pouvait être une généralité
je ne crois pas à lui madame cahoon a
causé comment était votre entourage
comment qui vous a écouté adolescente
adolescente et plus plus tard en moins
maintenant c'est bien accepté
je sais qu'au début mot dépression tv
n'étaient pas prononcés et may enfin moi
même avant tout ça
quand j'étais adolescente j'étais
monsieur opposés très très violemment à
mes parents enfin verbalement mais je
crois que ça m'a sauvé un petit peu ça a
dû être très dur pour eux c'était a été
sûrement mais c'était très dur aussi
pour moi et une fois mon père m'avait
menacée on va t'emmener chez le toubib
et et moi j'ai compris tout si je lui ai
dit c'est quoi c'est pas une menace
d'aller chez un médecin même si c'est un
psychiatre et alors
et puis vint finalement deux ans après
c'est ce qui s'est passé
le pauvre et est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que dans votre ville il ya
eu un déclic qu'à un moment donné qui
vous a fait basculer d'un côté ou de
l'autre
un choc quelque chose
qui me fait basculer dans la dépression
pas vraiment ça s'est passé comme ça
vraiment je crois qui a eu lieu un
concours de sûr pas un concours de
circonstances mais une somme de choses
de
kiné qui n'allait pas ça n'allait pas
chez moi ça n'allait pas au lycée
s'arrête pas dans ma tête c'était trop
[Rires]
est ce qu'on peut se rendre compte qu'on
va rentrer en dépression qu'on commence
une dépression c'est très variable nous
c'est vrai qu'il ya des pressions que
nous appelons endogène stamos avant ça
veut dire qu'ils n'ont aucune cause
psychologique connu et qui n'est
d'ailleurs pas de causes psychologiques
et qui surviennent pour les ont
totalement biologique à une date qui
dépend de facteurs que nous ne
connaissons pas dont beaucoup d'ailleurs
de ces facteurs sont des facteurs même
de saison on sait qu'il ya des saisons
qui sont propices à l'éclosion des
dépressions le printemps particulier et
l'automne
c'est dur je sais pas pourquoi fin le
soleil est revenu cet été ça va
peut-être mieux mais au début de l'année
j'ai trouvé que c'est nous mais salle le
matin l'automne sait parfaitement que
nous il ya même une chose assez curieuse
statistiquement parlant c'est que chez
les gens qui sont bipolaires taddei qui
font d état de dépression et d état
d'exaltation et fabrique curieusement
font plutôt des dépressions au printemps
au moment où tout bourgeonnent un moment
où en principe l'avironnais est il fondé
état de dépression d'exaltation au
printemps à la chute des feuilles
mauvaise c'est qu'il ya des facteurs qui
nous échappent complètement dans la
dépression endogène la survenue peut
être tout à fait indépendante de facto
psychologique mais ça ne veut pas dire
que les gens des privés en soit
convaincu parce que quand vous êtes
déprimé vous avez une vision tellement
dramatique de vous même et de ce qui
vous entoure que de cette vision
dramatique qui est la conséquence de la
dépression vous arriver très vite par
une erreur d'interprétation à faire la
cause
pression si tout d'un coup je me déprime
et que j'ai le sentiment je fais mal mon
métier je vais dire je suis non pas du
tout un monsieur qui a l'impression
qu'il fait mal son nom
déprimée parce qu'il s'est enfin rendu
compte qu'il faisait mal son métier avez
vous bien sûr ce qui fait que très
souvent il faut se méfier quand les gens
disent je suis déprimé ce pas étonnant
parce que je ne suis pas fait pour faire
ce que je fais parce que je ne supporte
pas mon mari qui est tel ou tel défaut
et quand cette personne redevient normal
elle vit avec ses défauts de sonneries
c'est la vie en fait être un drame
permanent à partir du moment où on la
présente d'une certaine manière ce qui
me surprend pas se passer des gens des
blessés qui n est pas plus parce que
finalement la vie est dramatique un
enfant qui naissent d'un condamné à mort
où ils wessels un drame de la solitude
vous aimez 7 grammes de l'inquiétude et
cetera enfin bon les acteurs vous allez
d'être email non mais vous mes lecteurs
le dimanche c'est déjà beaucoup donc ce
qu'il ya une force en nous une force
biologie qui est l'élan vital et qui
fait que pour les gens l'essentiel c'est
de vivre moi j'ai vu en cour d'assises
comme c'était jeune étudiant je
regardais enfin les procès d'assises
j'ai vu un jour un type condamné aux
travaux forcés à perpétuité sauter de
joie embrassé son avocat comme s'il
avait le prix goncourt il échappé à la
guillotine il était condamné
c'est ça la vie c'est ça la vérité les
déprimés eux ont le sentiment que tous
ces gens là sont des farfelus sont sont
des naïfs et qui ne perçoivent pas
justement que la vie d'un drame
permanent mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il ya bien sûr des dépressions tout à
fait réactionnelle j'ai vu des centaines
de gens déprimés parce qu'ils ont perdu
leur situation des femmes parce qu'elles
ont été abandonnées bon ça c'est bien
connu est né le nier serait absurde mais
il y à des tops des pressions continues
tu es méchant de jeunes qui arrivent
comme les cheveux sur la soupe et
parfois avec une brutalité inouïe vous
avez connu jacqueline de segonzac vous
savez qui c'est et si un extraordinaire
témoignage sur sa propre maladie
demirel donnons aux abymes des pressions
oui elle a écrit un très beau livre
s'appelle le délire et le deuil sur sa
maladie et je me rappelle nous ont fait
l'émission ensemble sur france culture
où quelqu'un mais comment commencer
dépression elle racontait qu'un jour est
en train de faire une descente à ski et
au milieu de la descente sans aucune
raison tout d'un coup il a senti qui a
été livrée mais comme dit les 110 j'en
prenais pour neuf mois au milieu de sa
descente il ya des gens qui peuvent
dater le début de leur dépression non
seulement au jour près mais à l'heure et
la minute prévue dès ce moment où j'ai
fermé la route tourner la clé de contact
que j'ai senti que ça y était que
c'était parti et inversement on peut
sentir à déclic comme disent les malades
et qui veut dire ça y est je suis je
vais bien et alors dans le cas d'une
dune de claudine et et même de votre
voisine quand ça commence à l'enfance
alors c'est tout à fait différent parce
que la diorite si l anorexie non sans
doute à fait différent parce que la
dépression dont je parle est une
anorexie sont des choses sont les
problèmes tout à fait différent
l'anorexie est quelque chose qui se
développe à partir de l'adolescence et
qui est essentiellement un état
névrotique la dépression est un état de
crise a dit en dépression nerveuse audi
nerveuse parce que vous savez ça fait
partie des effets mise vous savez que
l'anorexie on appelle la mauricie
anorexie mentale et on est en train de
revenir là dessus parce que le mot
mentale à une très mauvaise connotation
mental ça fait fou pour les anorexiques
ne sont pas fous alors ona mais crée le
on a proposé de dire anorexie nerveuse
parce que c'est moins stigmatisant oui
denisot voulais pas me suis horrifié
parce que justement les maladies
mentales est vrai fou il souffre aussi
de ce qu'on
on a là c'est un fou quelle horreur
ils auraient besoin aussi qu'on parle
d'eux que les maladies mentales soit
soit reconnu comme pas des maladies
honteuses non plus même les vrais fous
que ce soit pas des maladies honteuses
vous avez tout à fait raison mais le
fait est le fait est que pour les gens
qui ont par exemple une dépression
l'idée que la dépression puisse s
assimilé à une forme de maladie mentale
au sens le plus péjoratif du terme il
n'est évidemment pas pour un psychiatre
qui n'est pas pour un homme de coeur
mais qui n'est parce que c'est une des
hantises de nos malades n'est ce pas a
peur de devenir fou c'est à dire en fait
de ne plus commander cette heure là
oui parce que justement je pense que
c'est pour ça que je me suis battu parce
que je ne voulais absolument pas
rencontré un psychiatre ou un
psychologue ou quoi que ce soit
justement où moi je me pose toujours des
questions et je me reposerai toute ma
vie je crois c'est la distinction à
faire entre ce qui est normal et la
normale et où je pose énormément de
questions parce que je me dis que dans
notre société il faudrait correspondre
un certain type il faut être rentable il
faut correspondre à tel est l image ou à
telle est l équité étiquettes et ça me
enfin j'ai besoin de m'exprimer à ce
niveau là parce que à partir de quand
est ce que quelqu'un est normal ou
quelqu'un est alors mal est là est toute
la question
c'est toujours bon quand on fait un
grand tour d'horizon c'est peut-être un
peu philosophique mais ça m'intéresse
parce que bon si vous regardez la
société bien en face de vous même il ya
les enfants qui s'en sont exclus vous
avez les femmes qu'elles soient
célibataires ou vieille fille comme les
autres guillemets puis ensuite vous avez
les femmes divorcées puis vous avez les
femmes veuves et puis vous avez les
vieillards puis vous avez les malades
mentaux et tout le monde est bien
gentiment repoussé dans sa petite case
et moi je trouve ça est excessivement
affreux quoi plus tard seulement je me
dis bon une dépression nerveuse je
dirais à la limite c'est un accident de
parcours par rapport à une succession
d'événements qui en ont fait que
ça n'a plus pu suivre aussi bien aussi
bien dans le sens psychologique que
physique du terme
non mais ce qu'il faut répondre à votre
question c'est une très bonne question
c'est que nous sommes tous différents
les uns des autres et il n'y a pas de
norme c'est ça les génies sont des gens
profondément pas normaux ouais non qu'on
aimerait bien avoir des enfants
mentionnés génie
et chacun à ce que j'appelle d'un terme
qui n'est pas très distinguée à une
fiche technique qui correspond à ce
qu'ils aient enfin quand vous achetez le
machine qui étaient soit un téléviseur
par exemple une fiche technique qui
causent pas un téléviseur et nous avons
nous une définition espérant si j'étais
la bruyère n'est ce pas je pourrai
définir pierpoljak tel qu'il est quand
il est normal quand il a raté dans son
état de fonctionnalités normale et la
dépression c'est une dérive par rapport
à ça prié vous et les gens nous le
disent bien quand par exemple une femme
étaient primés son mari ne lis mes
docteurs n'a jamais été comme ça moi je
l' ai connu elle était vivante et
dynamique elle était toujours prête à
foncer et c'est tant pis tout d'un coup
je découvre quelque chose que je ne
comprends plus bon c'est cette dérive on
est simplement une automobile qui a une
bougie qui ne marche pas cette
automobile devient un veau rapport à ce
qu'elle était mais tout vient ce
dérèglement ce dérèglement est un
dérèglement qui est biologique et ce
alors c'est aujourd'hui une chose qui
est parfaitement connue n'est pas la
difficulté c'est que les gens n'arrivent
pas à se représenter que le cerveau est
un organe le plus complexe de tous mais
le cerveau est un organe comme un titre
que le cratère alors on devrait pouvoir
parler d'insuffisance cérébrale comme on
parle d'insuffisance hépatique d'agir
très mal la science car ils n'ont pas
suffisant c'est ballot sens les débiles
mais bon héros qui n'en fonction c'est
un très très bon est ce que nous disons
là c'est pas simplement une intuition
c'est pas pour nous cliniciens une
évidence c'est pas quelque chose qui a
été par dessus le marché parfaitement
prouvées par l'efficacité des
traitements biologiques non pas dans
tous les cas ne fait pas dire ça marche
toujours mais dans un nombre de capes
tels que le hasard ne veut pas être mis
en cause mais à l'heure qu'il est en ce
moment nous sommes en train de pouvoir
mettre en évidence chez le déprimé des
paramètres biologiques qui exprime la
réalité de sa dépression comme on
exprime la réalité d'une hépatite parler
transaminases dans le sang
c'est à dire que dans quelques années
quand ces choses seront banal au lieu de
dire d'un déprimés comme nous le disons
aujourd'hui il n'a qu'à se secouer il
n'a qu'à prendre sur lui nous
connaîtrons la valeur de ces paramètres
comme on sait aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui
a 30 de tension a trop de tension
commençait bien g de cholestérol qui a
un trop et on dira de madame molle par
exemple dit elle est venue faire son
émission à la carabine sérotonine attend
chapeau ce n'est pas du tout une déprime
et qui est bien qu'ici faire une
prestation médiocre c'est une héroïne
fait il y avait un fils de 6 ans puis
qui s'appelait les héros sont fatigués
et la musique les fatiguer sont des
héros un jour on le saura pas ce qu'on
sera contre quoi ils se battent n'est ce
pas cas on parle de volonté pour les
goûters ce secteur vente et si on juge
la volonté sur le résultat à déprimer
est un aboulique si on juge
la volonté sur l'effort le déprimé est
un personnage extraordinairement
admirable celui de caen c'était très
grosse on me disais mais dont un peu de
volonté mais gris mangent moins et
maintenant que je suis moins grosses on
me dit est donc un peu
développée en hongrie et mange plus mal
d'espoir sens
c'est pas une question de volonté enfin
je veux dire
au fond de soi on ne désire pas à
vraiment en studio mais qu'est-ce que je
fais là de façon enfin pour moi c'est ça
ce jeu me dit tout
de
l'avis ne rapporte plus rien
d'intéressant je me laisse pour le
moment et pourtant on en sort puisque
madame de guidage denise emma lamadji il
en est sorti on en sort mans risque de
retombées beaucoup plus enfin facilement
je veux dire si on a déjà fin à mon avis
si on a fait déjà fait une dépression ne
plus de risques d'en refaire que le lien
qui n'en a jamais fait mais aussi moi je
trouve que au fur et à mesure en a plus
d'éléments aussi pour s'en sortir plus
vite on en sort windows et l'ailier se
dit oui je vous en prie que tel
quelquefois je pense je me dis si je
m'en sors et bien après je serait
drôlement forte avec mon mari parce que
après tout ce qu'on a traversé là je
pense qu'on aurait traversé le plus dur
et j'espère que ça ira mieux après
oui je voulais par le docteur du support
de la psychologie oui ou de l'analyse
j'ai tenté une analyse lorsque j'ai eu
c'est plus mauvais moment mon ex-mari et
l'analyse a n'a pas du tout réussi parce
que
c'est m6 tient après ça n'a pas du tout
marché
je dois je dois donner quand même un
témoignage ce psychiatre me faisait
payer davance le moi
et il m'a dit qu'un jour ils ne feraient
jamais une analyse avec un os de chez
renault ce que je tenais à le dire parce
que bon il m'a fallu quand même deux ans
pour
et après ensuite jeu
je suis allé j'ai été guidé par une
assistante sociale qui m'a envoyé dans
un dispensaire et depuis trois ans je
suis donc en entretien avec une
psychologue ça et ça ma part d'une
armurerie dont la dépression et dans le
tréfonds de la dépression la
psychanalyse ne plus rien apporter
ferenczi km c'est quelqu'un qui est très
déprimée c'est comme s'il ya quelqu'un
qui est en train de se noyer ont donné
de bord de la barque des conseils sur
son battements de pieds pain c'est
absolument dérisoires vous fait rire
clos des lys allons bon mais
c'est exactement comparable n'est pas
seulement ce qui est vrai c'est que 1
des prix mais c est aussi un point qui
est important un déprimé peut-être
quelqu'un qui quand il correspond à sa
fiche technique dont vous parlais tout à
l'heure et l'homme le plus équilibré de
la terre par la personne la plus
dynamique la plus équilibrée peut être
un jour elle frappée par la dépression
si je vous disais combien j'ai vu de
gens et que tout le monde pouvait
tanvier par leur équilibre connaître un
jour brutalement la dépression
incompréhensible et sans cause
extérieure dans tous les médias d'état
dans tous les milieux et je dirais même
que devant je fais alors balayer tout à
fait ce que dit ma voisine de gauche
c'est horrible et malheureusement
vraisemblable le psychiatre oui c'est
lui manquant jeudi soit semblable c'est
vrai oui
je ne veux pas tout à fait mais il ya il
veut balayer une objection qu'on nous
fait tout le temps n'est ce pas la
dépression est une maladie de riches
d'oise ifs est une réflexion absolument
stupide ce tube à ce qui est vrai c'est
que quand les gens sont riches et se
paye un psychiatre je dirais quotidien
chic et que etc mais vous savez à un
rockefeller quand il est déprimé c'est
un déprimé riche mais sa pauvre déprimé
valait mieux être déprimé être tower
peut-être mieux et en bonne santé rien
n'est ce pas que faut vraiment important
c'est bien joli mais la dépression n'est
pas du tout une maladie de gens riches
et le savon statistiquement parlant au
contraire céderait mieux où il ya des
difficultés qui a le plus de dépression
en revanche est juste important je
disais ça au début j'ai pas continuer
quand j'étais cadet pression est un peu
pour quelque chose donc on pourrait
presque être fier sur la n'était pas
aussi malheureux c'est que si la
dépression est une chose très répandu
j'avais des chiffres elle est d'autant
plus répandue dans un milieu que ce
milieu a plus de valeur je veux dire que
si vous considérez les gens qui sont des
grands créateurs si vous prenez les
grands écrivains si vous prenez les
grands musiciens si vous prenez les
grands mystères
si vous prenez
les artistes en général c'est une
hypersensibilité aux sons gens là font
des dépressions mais je ne dirais pas
dans la proportion de 10% ce qui est le
taux de morbidité parce que j'ai dit que
3% des gens des dépressions en
permanence afin que 3 % à vocation était
déprimé en permanence mais nous avons
tous une chance sur dix d'avoir été
d'être de devenir des prix mais c'est le
dire que ce qui veut dire que tout ce
qu'on dit de la dépression est très
précieux parce que ça touche toujours
des gens qui sont ou nous-mêmes ou de
notre famille ou proches de nous c'est à
dire que ce qu'on apprend c'est la
dépression est toujours utile parce que
ça peut toujours servir à servir à
d'autres pouvons toujours quand je vois
caméra était déprimé judic que il a
gagné dans sa dévotion au moins une
chose c'est d'être beaucoup plus ouvert
et beaucoup plus compréhensif à quantité
de situations qu'il rencontrera
quotidiennement alors que si vous
devenez très calés sur le scorbut sur le
béribéri sérieuse avance pas beaucoup
madame maquillage voulait dire quelque
chose de quoi l'instant disons que là je
le rejoins très fort je suis d'accord
parce que moi je pense que ça pourra
partir de là que je me suis dit en être
sorti moi je dis il faut avoir parfois
le courage et pouvoir témoigner et de
dire aux autres comment éventuellement
on en est sorti et puis qu'on puisse à
noah nous nous mêmes aidés et ceux qui
sont dedans sortir le disais tout à
l'heure que vous ne et plus envie de
rien plus envie de vous et pourtant vous
avez fait l'effort de venir aujourd'hui
porter votre témoignage pourquoi avez
vous fait ça dans quel but d'abord parce
que je rencontre qu'en parler c'est très
important ça libère d'ailleurs quand on
quand un bon ministre on libère quelque
chose
on vomit tous et ses rancunes ses
regrets tout vraiment
jusqu'au fond
et puis
parler c'est un peu la reynerie voilà
parler c'est exactement pareil ça fait
du bien surtout quand les gens qu'on a
en face de soi
ne se sentent pas responsables de ce
n'est pas parce que quand on parle à des
gens qui sont très proches
ils peuvent croire qu'on s'adresse à eux
en les incriminant en leur disant ben je
suis comme ça parce que tu n'as pas été
assez assez bien alors quand même
content non c'est pas ça du tout mais ça
fait tellement de bien de de pouvoir en
parler
et dévoila et de sentir qu'on n'ait pas
condamné d'emblée on peut s'en sortir
sans sortir sans médicaments de pêche
d'abord on s'en sort toujours pour une
bonne raison c'est qu'une dépression
seuil est toujours très aguerris
touchera toujours et toujours sauf
naturellement si un point les gens sauf
si les gens se suicident alors là c'est
cette histoire à propos de ça que je
voulais vous poser une question parce
que bon je ne pense pas que tous les
déprimés passe nécessairement par le
suicide oui même envie de passer par ce
que je peux vous donner un je vous
dirais franchement je peux je n'ai
jamais eu envie je veux vous dire non
seulement que le débat ne suscite pas
messieurs moi qui envoie beaucoup il
m'est arrivé de passer quatre années
sans qui est un seul suicide pas mais
les gens que ce soit n'y ait pas
d'incident s'est quand même heureusement
pas courant mais c'est quand même une
chose qui peut arriver parce que le
déprimé vraiment très malheureux et que
désespoir fait partie de la dépression
place et qui distingue le malade des
primes et des autres malades c'est qu'il
n'y a pas d'espoir très souvent n'osent
pas toujours mais il n'a pas d'espoir
alors que les autres malades sont des
battants il est épais mais lui il est
battu
à écouter merci je crois qu'on aurait pu
continuer sur cette question de la
dépression pendant des heures et des
heures encore on n'a pas du tout abordé
le problème de la thérapeutique
spécifique et particulièrement celle des
médicaments qui doivent accompagner les
soins donnés aux déprimé mais vous voyez
il ya au moins trois personnes sur ce
plateau qui s'en sont sortis on peut
donc sortir de la dépression merci de
nous avoir prêté attention à bientôt au
revoir
[Musique]